[Music]
let's go to michael in macon bacon
georgia what's up michael
dr john thank you for taking my call
this afternoon uh listen here's my
question i'm a pastor
dude are you a pastor you have a pastor
voice
how did you how did you get that
i have no idea so listen i grew up my
dad was in radio was in broadcast
journalism so
maybe i was supposed to be on the radio
and i wound up preaching but who knows
dude you sound way better at this than i
am
that's incredible man
all right so sorry i was about to
interrupt you
let me know are you are you a pastor man
for real that's incredible your voice
all right so what's up
so i had pastor here in in middle
georgia little town called perry and
i'm working on my preaching plan for
next year and i'm working on a series of
messages
to address problematic emotions from a
biblical perspective like from the
gospel and so my question for you is
what are some what you would say best
resources uh for research and for sermon
prep might even have some good
application
to make this the scriptural applications
for my people
not a lot of people asked me for
insights to their sermons michael
well
well i'm
i read your book redefining anxiety okay
i listen to i listen to your show
regularly and um
i usually listen to you at one and a
half speed so you do sound good at one
and a half speed uh
but as i read through the book obviously
it starts with the you know with the
proverb right at the very beginning and
then you define the problem very clearly
and then bring the the application in
really well and so i thought you know
that that kind of resource is helpful
for a lay person such as myself who's
not necessarily obviously i'm not a
psychologist or psychiatrist or well
dealt in that so how do i help bring
those two worlds together and that's
where that practical application is is
needed it's helpful yeah that's so good
what a great question so
what i've noticed over the last 15 or 25
20 years i'll just leave it at 15 20
years
is
a temptation by pastors to
both the temptation and this weird
expectation
to become experts in everything
and
to have an opinion or to speak on
everything as though they are
at ground zero with those particular
things
and
now we've got pastors who are speaking
on all sorts of issues you know what i'm
talking about this is clearly not you
but it's other your colleagues for sure
not you
um
and so i think what a great place to
start when it comes to a discussion on
emotions a discussion on
what you say you want to talk about
emotions biblical emotions
yeah so i'm really
calling problematic emotions so things
like anxiety anger grief
um a along a long line so the i mean the
reality of pastoral ministry is that
these are the conversations and so i
mean i do i do pastoral counseling and i
have a a seminar and a post-seminary
degree and training and this kind of
thing um
and so these are the conversations that
i have so from a from like a ministry
standpoint a lot of it is really we're
talking about is biblical discipleship
helping people to understand their
situation and see it in the in the
through the lens of the gospel right and
then some of that then some people need
to they they need more help they need to
spend time with um
with a trained uh counselor in that area
and that kind of thing so i'm not trying
to be more than i can be oh yeah yeah
yeah gotcha got you guys but i know that
people are sitting in the in the in the
seats and these are the things that are
happening behind the closed doors at
home
that they that they have yet to be
willing to drag out in the light ah okay
okay
yeah so it kind of drives a lot from the
the pastoral side of the ministry yeah
um
you know we're so pastoring and
preaching come together and and meet
there um so that's that's that's where
it's really being driven from gotcha so
number one
i want to just applaud you for leading
your church through how can i help my
people live more peaceful lives how can
i let them
teach them to be better parents and
better
spouses and better neighbors
um and that starts with dealing with
handling these emotions right where are
these things coming from what are they
about what i've found over the last year
working here at ramsey is
letting somebody know hey the reason
you're so raged out is because your
brain's trying to take care of you not
because of this thing on politics you
think is happening it's because this
thing over here is poking on you
it's giving people
right or uh one of my favorite
theological quotes of all time is from
rich mullins which is we often over
spiritualize jesus and i think there's
an incredible
an incredible
sermon series that can be done on the
human
the guy who
had his heart broken the guy who was
exhausted the guy who was
laying on on on his face saying the guy
who had doubt dad can we do it another
way i don't do it like this
the guy who then got up and went anyway
right so when it comes to emotions the
things that i want people to always know
is we live in a world and i'm trying to
do a third way here you may have heard
me say that
we live in a world that's either forget
your feelings forget your emotions get
over it quit being angry suck it up
or
we the other
swath of our culture is all about
your feelings are everything what do you
feel and if you don't feel loved or
happy or good then you do you and yolo
and all that right
right the third way is and i think it's
modeled biblically is
now you got to feel that stuff and then
go
and then go do
and so what i always want to
i like to start with experts man
and not always
academic experts
but i love talking to somebody who might
be a marriage counselor i like my would
love my church to to hear those kind of
people i love getting um
genesis lessons from a biologist it's
awesome
it's a complete reframe right so if i'm
you i would look at a couple of core
emotions chip dodd's got some stuff out
there um henry cloud and townsend with
boundaries and stuff that there are some
problems that we can address and by
addressing those problems we end up
getting into the feelings and the
emotions part then we end up getting in
the how does that apply to me here's
what i mean
sometimes let's talk about being angry
it's easy to go i'm not angry i just
drive 95 miles an hour and dig my
fingernails into the into my car right
i'm not angry sometimes
especially men we tend to to shy away
from our emotions
i love to come at things more
problem-based that's why we do this call
this show people might look on there and
say dude i got nothing to learn from
somebody with bipolar disorder and we
get to the end and they're like oh gosh
i need to take control of fill in the
blank
so similarly
if i'm doing a series on emotions i
might do a series on
how to be a better dad
because a part of being a better dad
means
pausing before i speak and feeling my
body as it gets angry and then asking
myself
surely it's not from a four-year-old
where is this anger coming from oh it's
lack of control it's fear it's that i'm
terrified it is whatever right
okay um i
how to be
less anxious
what's a biblical discussion of what
depression looks like
and i a firm believer with all my heart
that the
science of mental health and the
neurology and all the neuroscience all
of that lines up
i mean you're talking about ancient
wisdom it all lines up it's like the
joke with us it's like it's like the new
old wisdom
it all lays on top of itself right so
there's nothing to be afraid of in fact
it's exciting for me i like watching it
when it lines up that way
so i'm going to start with prob that
this is just me you start however you
want i mean if you want to talk about do
a whole series on feelings chip dad's
got a book out on feelings that that's a
good resource just to walk people with
the with i think he's got seven core
feelings some have 15 core feelings some
have five whatever you can do that i
just know in my life i tend to go i'm
not emotional so i don't need this
lesson it's not for me i'll just play on
my phone
but if you say hey how to be a better
husband i'll listen to you i'll give you
10 minutes on that and see if you can
convince me
or how to get a good night's sleep
you know you talk about the fruits of
the spirit is there anything more
peaceful
than a guy falling asleep on a boat when
everybody else is thinking they're gonna
drown
like there's just a level right peace
there like what we don't even know what
that feels like man so that's where i
would look at it and then reverse
engineer it does that answer your call i
feel like i'm just rambling at you now
no it it does it helps it helps very
much um
so obviously in that opening you you've
got to you've got a hook you've got to
give them the reason that they say hey i
need to stay dialed in and listen to
what to what he has to say what he's
sharing so that it's extremely helpful
the way you backed into that the other
thing is i want after people feel those
feelings i want them to demand evidence
from them is this true or is this not
true and if i can get somebody to demand
evidence instead of acting on that
feeling
the whole world changes
the whole world changes
if somebody cuts me off
and instead of flipping them off
grabbing my gun tailgating them somebody
cuts me off
and i
can pause and say what am i so mad about
and i go oh i don't
i don't i lack control here i feel in
the blank film like then i can calm down
and slow down man because tail getting
them is not going to do anything but put
me at greater risk than what they just
right so can i
just have a gap there and then on teach
people man
i don't know what's happened to you in
the past
everybody i know has got garbage some
worse than others but we all have to
wake up today and say what are we going
to do today
right
and that's getting up the next day after
the garden and saying i don't want to do
this
and then saying
but i'll go
yeah yeah what i mean like i
that guy didn't want to stop and
with the
you know the samaritan would want to
stop and wherever he was going and pay
for that dude's bills
but here i am and
now i get to choose what i do next
right and that to me becomes the message
you gotta feel your feelings and then
demand evidence and then you gotta go do
whatever that looks like for you and if
i can help people walk through that then
the emotion stuff tends to work
themselves out man
okay that's excellent that's extremely
helpful to uh to
to think that through right so i love
how you said that it helped them to feel
the feeling
and then demand evidence of that feeling
what's true what's real what's really
true
our feelings lie to us a lot
our feelings are just our body's way of
trying to communicate with us right and
our body if it can communicate that
we're gonna die
it will
get us out of a situation it will help
us fight a situation or help us free
it'll help us hide in a situation but it
keeps us alive and that's our body's job
our body's job is not to help us have
great marriages or to have good jobs
long term or to make good investment
decisions
body's jobs keep you alive
and man sometimes those feelings they
lie to us they over sensationalize they
over dramatize they whatever because the
body's trying to get a reaction out of
you
can i just feel that feeling and go
this is
crappy
i mean i'm in a season of mourning that
hurts and still i got to go eat right
man she really hurt me just now
i'm still going to empty the dishwasher
because that's what i said i would do
if i if we can get people to do that in
our churches in our schools and our
communities we're talking about a
different planet right
yeah i think over the years uh the
church that not has not intentionally
meant to be this way but i think we've
we've probably simplified or not really
answered the questions that people are
asking and so because we don't know what
to say we just say simple platitudes
like well you know you just need to pray
about it not that prayer not the
discipline of prayer is not integral in
the spiritual growth and the the victory
that people have in this um but they're
they're they're dealing with real
feelings and really trying to live you
know monday through friday and and do it
well like ultimately you know life is
complicated and they're just trying to
get it right and so i feel like they
have questions and i'm just not certain
that we've really taken the time as the
church to answer them in a healthy way
that roots them back into the into the
scriptures i think we've just been
afraid
i think the church is afraid to address
things that might get a little messy to
be honest with you i think the
church is as a whole has
absolutely
embarrassingly dismally um met the needs
of their of the questions people and
their churches are asking i think you're
exactly right and it takes a group of
brave pastors like yourself to lean in
and say what are y'all hurting with
we'll start there
yeah and man i'm telling you you get a
group of people
i think the same thing with our school
system man i think the same thing with
politic people are talking about what
are you talking about
i don't even know what that means you
know what i mean
right i i i can't tell you the number of
times i've heard a sermon and i just
looked at my wife like what are you
talking about
i don't know what you're even saying
or i'm sitting in a in a
like a continuing ed program like
do you hear the words coming out of your
mouth it doesn't even make sense it's
just a platitude unt yeah on the top of
a body you have to have a platitude
it's time that all of us get very
intentional about the real questions
people are asking
and well because those are real people
in the scriptures i mean jesus is real
and uh you know the gerson demoniac was
a real person and nicodemus was a real
person and zacchaeus was a real person
and david and goliath and you know peter
and paul all these they're they're
they're real people this is not like
aesop's fables or whatever and so there
are human emotions that are played out
as you've pointed out already that are
played out on the pages of the
scriptures in front of us
and so
um i mean even jesus described as he
went from town to town he described the
people as
as harassed and helpless like sheep
without a shepherd i mean that was how
he first observed people you know when
he when he walked when he walked into
town and then he went to the business of
teaching
ministering and healing and bringing
healing so he you know he was he was not
just
dropping you know making mike drop
moments with his uh you know this
theology he was applying that in real
life and helping people right where they
were at and that's that's what we're
trying trying to do they all created
some conversation with people also he
got people water
right you know what i mean or he
talked to women when women weren't
supposed to be talked to he went into
situations that people said you
shouldn't be there
and he's like no this is where i'm at
right and so there's there's an action
to it there's a disruptive
um
there's a disruptive spirit
i'm going to be about loving people
and that means i'm going to get in the
mess and i'm going to get between
somebody trying to hurt you i'm going to
get i'm going to sit down on the ground
and draw on the dirt that's how close to
this thing i'm gonna get
and
yeah man
if if we get it you know
like go ahead and say we know we're the
minister we're gonna you know to
minister that grace and love of jesus
and it just can't be slung at uh from a
distance i mean now you have to step in
to
step into those lanes uh you know not
taking on i can't take on everybody's i
can't take on everybody's problems i did
that as a young pastor thinking that i
was no i fix everything
yeah you get fried and cooked and burned
out that's exactly right but that's
right and i took it all home and so um
but you still got to be able to step
into those lanes and meet people where
they're at that's exactly right and i
think i think a humility of a pastor to
say
i tonight or this morning i brought in
for 20 minutes of the 40 minutes
a first responder who's running the
street right now here's what our
neighborhoods look like
here's the fear this person feels
and then tying that back me let me we
learned through story jesus taught
through parables we learned through
narrative
um
uh
i won't get down that road that's more
of a controversial road but
we learn through story we learn through
experience here as a teacher here's what
her world has been the last 24 months
so when you talk about anxiety this is
what this feels like when it talks about
carrying burdens here's what this
actually feels like and the more we can
make this stuff real the more we can
make these lessons not just so these
things that you sew on a pillow but a
way we treat each other the way we lean
into discomfort a way that we sit with
people on the margins of our society
dude you're talking everything
everything changes
everything changes and people just start
talking way way way way less
and loving and doing way way way more
so thank you so much for calling if that
helps man
there's a reason nobody asked me
to preach